this show is brought to you by score big
listen guys it's almost baseball season
you're gonna want to go to games but a
lot of places are sold out like Boston
Red Sox games always sell out always
next time you're about to go to a game
go to scorebig.com first and see how
much you can save go to scorebig.com
right now and click on the microphone
it's right at the top it's in a like a
red background and a microphone click on
it and then enter promo code Joey and
you'll save an extra 20 bucks off your
first purchase that's 20 off your first
purchase and I went and checked they
have opening day tickets to the Fenway
Park for Red Sox it's crazy you can't
get those anywhere so go to scorebig.com
click on the microphone and use promo
code Joey and then go to anna.com and
use promo code Church to get 10 off all
the great optimization products I tried
the uh the uh Dolce protein today it was
delicious delicious I liked it it was
great I'll see how it goes it's only my
first day but it was good and so just go
to promo go to audit.com promo code
Church to save 10 off
thank you
and you thought
you had nothing going on tonight oh [__]
what did you [__] up
oh [__]
March [__] 29th that's what's
gonna happen [__]
let's dance
oh [__]
you bad [__]
the Church of What's Happening Now
Wednesday night March 30th March 29th
I'm sorry
April Fool's weekend who gives a [__]
here we go
little Michael Jackson's brothers in
83-84 putting it together look at them
here we go oh [__]
foreign
what's going on over there [__] Mr
Dancing Chef so how many groups did the
Jacksons have then because so there was
the I I thought it was gonna be the
Jackson 5 when you told me about it but
to the Jacksons it's the Jackson Five
then
Michael Jackson and his brother left
okay all right Michael Jackson went solo
and Jermaine went to Motown and started
his solo label with he stayed with Barry
Gordy
because he was married to Barry Gordy's
daughter
so the Jacksons left I think they went
to Epic Records I'm not sure don't
[__] quote me on that
and then what happened was if so the
Jacksons replaced Michael with Randy
Jackson
who was the baby Jackson who used to
play the Bongos and was cute and ship
ain't no Michael Jackson I'm surprised
they let it look at other stories he
left so Michael had to go solo you know
he wanted to go solo he didn't want to
be a Motown no more whatever
so the beauty of this was that
all right so Michael did the greatest
hits
Made It Off the Wall okay Off the Wall
came out like 81-82 I went to the show
with Kurt Delorenzo
15 [__] dollars
and the garden was not solder
it was like a Tuesday night it was not
sold out and I was blown away he did
some Jackson 5 songs and he did Off the
Wall songs
then Thriller came out
and then he did a song by a guy named
with a guy named Maxwell Somebody's
Watching Me Maxwell turned out to be
Barry Gordy's son or nephew
he was doing a favor for him to get his
career on track
so Michael Jackson blew up with Thriller
I guess he did a world tour with the
brothers it was Michael Jackson it was
called The Jacksons and they put the
album out called Victory which came out
when checking out victory
by The Jacksons came out maybe uh 84
February of 84 March 84 Maybe
something like that
let's see it was up July 2nd of 84. what
the [__] you think you're dealing with
but Thriller was already out
you're following me Thriller had come
out [__] the year before okay
so Drilla was on two years before
November of 82. gorilla was just on
[__] fire at this point
they released this album and had two
songs out of the [__] seven albums it
was no barn burner
but Michael Jackson did a world tour
again in the summer of 84 and I saw him
with
the brothers
right okay there was nine nights
New Jersey Meadowlands then the
following week Bruce Springsteen came in
with the board in the USA [__]
door
and he did nine nights who would you
compare
Michael Jackson two like celebrity wise
because I I was too young to know I like
I knew of him but like when he was huge
like for people now like Taylor Swift
like I'm like I'm just trying to think
about like who
Kardashian bigger than the Kardashian
like he was into that
like in 84 it was over like the summer
of 84 it was [__] over
he ran [__] it was him Prince with
[__] Purple Rain
Bruce Springsteen it was the last great
[__] summer
like I saw probably
not exaggerating I just remember off the
top of my head you forget I saw the
Jacksons
The Pretenders Rod Stewart Huey Lewis
and the News
you know I was still living in New York
City and I was in the city you know it's
a big difference when you yeah I live in
no no no I was in the city every [__]
day so I had my heart beat on tickets
and shows and little things you know and
saying like you're aware of what's going
on I worked at a bar at a hotel so the
concierge knew what was going on they
knew people who had tickets you know at
the end of the night I got an extra
tickets for you know what I'm saying
like oh you want to go to this club
there's a film Premiere and [__] like
that I never really went to those I
liked all the music stuff how is Michael
live
[__] mind-boggling man like just you
sit there and go what the [__] but for
me it was something different because I
grew up on the guy
I was here when ABC went off I still
remember buying the hour maybe you see
from the window like running in and
going that's the album I won and my
godfather buying it for me and me going
home at 11 and still [__] putting it
on and my mom's like what are you
[__] crazy it's 11 o'clock and that
type of [__] like I still remember being
five or six
buying that album
but I was with somebody I was at my
godfather we were by 42nd street and you
knew of it already you were like I heard
this song on the radio ABC you're a
[__] five-year-old you're a
five-year-old kid ABC's what you live
for and all of a sudden this [__]
black kid comes out and sings the song
ABC is easy as one two three this is
right in your [__] neighborhood they
were hugging you from childhood they
hooked you right there they hooked me I
was his age I was maybe a year younger
maybe two years [__] younger than
Michael Jackson so
you know for me I was there I was there
when that came out I want you back and
you know [__] the love you save and
then bend with the [__] Mouse which
nobody remembers he sang the song to Ben
so it was Willard then then Willard was
a movie about rats a kid who had rats
and these attacks send the rats on you
the rats lived in the basement he'd feed
him and if you [__] them with me feed
the [__] rats on you oh my god throw
on a clip from Willard go ahead Willard
19 [__] 70 or something like that
can't believe you don't know this [__]
this is the creepiest that is not a
movie yeah and then they remade it with
the kid but nobody knew what the [__] it
was Willard when I was a kid was the
scariest most disturbing [__] film I
ever saw as a child and I saw a bunch of
chop movies I shouldn't have [__] saw
as a child this [__] was [__]
disturbing wait till you watch this
[__] video or the trailer for it
now like I said
it also was released
they did a remake of it with I forget
the kid his father was in hard times
they didn't say
what happened didn't they I don't know
the team the TV might have gone
I guess [__] uh
that's what happens when you come in an
hour before the [__] show and check
things out of [__]
he comes here I get here at seven and I
check stuff out really
I get in there you text him back and
forth with movies what's on [__]
Netflix
Jesus Christ I've seen I did I had
Willard John Stewart you want to do the
downstairs one yeah let's see that okay
that's the one that's the it should be
the [__] one
but see if they got the tree this is a
trailer no it's not no no no Lily the
movie yeah yeah Jesus Christ right here
part one do you want to watch that one
or do you want to look no the trailer
okay Willard capitalized Willard
so they know you there you go much will
watch this You're Gonna Learn suddenly
watch this Scoopy [__]
[Music]
I already don't like it look look at
this look up here
Willard takes good care of them and they
will do anything nope
nope he was taking the parties and [__]
this is my nightmare
you made me hate myself
well I like myself now well your
nightmares and
I told you
there's rats everywhere
no
is the one
the one telling you dog what the [__] do
you think you do listen people I don't
know nothing about movie I don't know
nothing about stars and meteors and
[__] what happens in London I don't
give a [__] but when it comes to creepy
[__] movies Uncle Joey runs the
[__] Gambler right
put on Willow put on another scene from
just the movie it's [__] crazy let me
tell you something I forgot to Earnest
Borgnine was in that movie this is legit
movie people
Ernest blog 1970 here I am seven years
old I can barely [__] speak English I
end up at this [__] movie about rats
now when you're sitting here
watching rats one thing I remember about
this movie was that everything became
hypersensitive like my own foot scared
my own foot like give it like have your
foot touch your other foot oh yeah like
that's how scary that movie was like I I
left that too I couldn't do it I'd jump
like a little girl I couldn't do it I'm
just goofing on you I couldn't deal with
this [__] at that age but to think that
this came out and then they redid the
[__] thing
and they couldn't the kid couldn't uh
Jesus Christ was the [__] kid's name
that we did it Glover Glover did it
Danny Glover no not the black [__]
dude that's the black actor come on
which I put in just put uh will it uh no
put full movie just so we could scare
the [__] out of here Lee
there you go but the full movie I just
put that scene right there complete yeah
let's see and yeah we our podcast gets
taken down but the entire Willard's up
there
this is the scariest [__] thing I
ever saw when I was little man I'm
telling you there was this and it was
the devil's tongue or the Devil's
Disciples or something I don't need to
put this on people be upset and stuff
okay it'll creep you out you ate four
stars you don't need this [__] you're
[__] life but there's a movie so the
sequel to this was Ben let's see the
trailer for Ben all right there you go
so Willie came out in 70. so I'm seven
and then the movie Ben came out there
you go trailer 72 what's this
oh no yeah where will it left off
look at this [__]
where Willard ended
then begins Ben is coming from Cinerama
releasing and this time he's not alone
it's been the last one from Willard's
pack
oh damn
[Music]
pages from Willard's diary in the
newspapers
[Music]
there's a [__] up movie guys
I see Socrates
Ben was somebody's son look at him
no
you look like
it was like the studio out of money they
could just hire rats
[Music]
the rats took over the city
why does he like them
and his army of rats are on the way
this is [__] crazy you see what I'm
saying though uh do you see how intense
the 70s was now what year did Ben come
out 72
so I was nine and I was already getting
traumatized by [__] rats that's why I
hate [__] rats now I'm thinking about
why I hate rats not the ones who snitch
that's [__] though uh these [__]
things these animals that live in New
York City that I saw growing up I saw a
[__] rat one time after this movie it
was one of my Godmother's buildings on
148th Street in the basement I was
taking the garbage out okay this [__]
rat's eyes no it was so [__] big
was so [__] big I saw his head he was
like a little [__] Chihuahua I ran
out of that this thing was gigantic no
these animals were huge I can't deal
with them either I've seen him in the
subway but that's about it what's up
Wayne New York uh both Boston and New
York I think I've been here I had mice
and then like I had a really old shitty
apartment my last semester in Boston so
I had my decided to catch up with mice
and rats are two different animals like
crazy
that would freak me out listen I don't
want to see none of this [__] when I
wake up in the middle of night I'm in my
old house in Jersey
when they built giant Stadium all those
rodents from sequel started moving up
north so we all of a sudden had a small
in the infestation like one or two of
them might be sitting TV and I'd watch
them run out
and run back in their [__] hole I
would [__] my pants I can't even sleep
at night I couldn't even [__] sleep
at night so
speaking of uh I did that podcast with
dice
yes it was so weird that people didn't
know what was going on like people
thought I got up like something was
going on like I'd gotten a text I just
want to clarify
I had gotten up that morning to go to
Ventura to do radio and then from there
I went to John McCarthy used to do his
podcast
and on the way to acupuncture dice
called and said I'm doing Rogan but I
can only do an hour my press schedule is
too crazy
why don't you meet me up there let's
blow a bone let's talk and then we'll do
the podcast I go you know what I can do
the same but I got to leave at 2 45 too
I have a four o'clock
that's why I did the podcast
that's why I had to leave people thought
about it I only ate 200 milligrams that
didn't even affect me oh yeah that
doesn't even do nothing to me but the
crazy thing was
people thought that I had to leave and
why was I not talking I wasn't talking
because it was Dyson's podcast
dice invited me to be on this podcast
I can't go on this podcast etiquette
there really isn't a lot of people don't
there really is a podcast etiquette we
had a guest about four months ago he
called me up like a man he wanted to
promote some okay
we brought him in the podcast wasn't in
one minute he's yelling the [__] date
that broke the podcast
now you're selling me I just wanted to
hear a [__] conversation
you know what I'm saying like that that
that's
it was kind of [__] weird let's start
off with a [__] conversation you just
don't go for a [__] you suck at titties
you kiss a neck you rub her [__] ears
and I think the issue might be is a lot
of people might not listen to podcasts
the people who are doing podcasts now
probably don't listen to other people's
podcasts well that's the thing you have
to have some type of podcast etiquette
that's why I don't get involved in more
than two people podcast nope I don't
like those big eight people podcasts
five people podcast because it doesn't
really matter because if I talk
that I'm talking too much and if I don't
talk I'm too [__] quiet you know what
here it's equal opportunity employer we
talk some [__] we smoke a few bones we
watch a video about [__] rats and
everybody goes home happy that's why I
don't get involved in those things and
conferences and what happened with the
[__] Festival they ever get back to
you no no I told you those things I
could put that's why I don't do
festivals because oh this is you getting
together with your buddies there's no
Dore me on them and at the end of the
week you'll get on the plane you go what
was that about
I just left my home for three nights to
do what to talk to a bunch I'm sure they
want to do it I don't know there's
there's a few of them that are doing it
but yeah it's weird it's we've we've
talked every time I've been involved in
the festival yeah
it's been amazing it's a by the way
there's always a by the way
because being part of a festival means
that you get to see your peers and hang
out and be a part of a panel and all
that [__]
but at the end of the day on the plane
you go what did I do
you were part of something for
you know what I'm saying like so every
Festival I did way I mean I did like
three or four festivals for comedy like
mediocre ones like the Toyota one in New
York
I did the Latino laugh Festival I did
the one here downtown
and I can tell you one thing
then do nothing for me
they weren't fun because like I've heard
Ari talk about he does a lot of
festivals because they're fun but he
loses money that's what he says that's
the bottom line
you don't want to lose money anymore I
don't want to have fun I don't have fun
I go to the circus
I get Ari I understand you know Ari
likes to go down then he stays up before
and they goof around they smoke joints
somebody that and then I don't want to
see somebody do the festival Anthem I
don't want to say that
I don't want to be a part of that at all
ever
ever it just doesn't interest you don't
want people no no not at all never
you know never like a couple years ago
when they were doing the left uh the
last Just for Laughs in Chicago they
asked
I'm good
I'm good is it because that are you like
angry because you didn't go to other
festivals
no just
years ago it's better than a wanted to
have
and a lot of times in life you'll
realize that and not pertaining to a
career but pertaining to a certain move
you want to do
sometimes you'll get involved in
something and we really don't think out
the [__] plan
but that's what life is all about
learning from not really a mistakes from
from experiences I don't consider mixed
mistakes I consider them experiences
there's a big difference between a
mistake and an experience
and you can have an experience and not
[__] like it at all
you can have an experience and not like
it or I might take it to Morocco you
might talk to eight [__] Momos at
Starbucks who they went to Morocco and
had great and they had the garlic on
they said Buddhas and when you go to
this hotel make sure you see Mumu is the
coolest guy around and and you get then
the guy smells like a goat and the food
is [__] horrible and you [__] blood
and there was [__] uh stains on your
mattress and you know the place stunk
like [__] I'm not saying that this is
what I'm just telling you from different
experiences so that experience for Joe
Diaz that he said it was great maybe you
ain't the same Philly are you going to
come up to me are you the type of guy
gonna come up to me and say you know
what Joey I love you to death but that
really sucked
no you're a nice guy you're gonna get
one good thing out of it well I went to
see a movie you know I know you I went
to see this movie in a festival and who
gives a [__] uh
so my point is that
I wanted when I first got into I wanted
to get the festival I said listen at the
Toyota festivals the soprano people
discovered me
I have no ill Wilson Festival
at the San Antonio Latino land Festival
one of the best experiences I have he'll
tell you he talks about it on stage with
Bobby Lee
who Me and Bobby Lee okay we're both
broke
flat broke we didn't know until we got
down that they were going to pay us in a
check
so do you have to go to like a cat
checking a check cashing place no no a
check that they were gonna mail us in a
month oh no and it was fifty dollars a
set and we did three sets that's 150
dollars
and they gave us a plane ticket in the
[__] back of the plane Bailey with
straps around our thing we flew out in
the air we had to wear a winter jacket
that's [__] up yeah and that was okay
there was no per diem
there was no discounted breakfast there
was nothing they took care of us in no
particular order so in New York I knew
what I expected all I wanted was a set
there so they put me in this [__]
show that was horrific obviously they
didn't know me I wasn't friends with
anybody so they put me to close the show
at 12 15 at night when everybody
disappeared do you understand me so now
you're not friends with the festival
dude so you follow me they put slots
and then there was one other one I did
the one I did downtown that one was
about
was I still doing blow
gotta be close to when I got off blow
and that was it
that was that that was that was it that
was it
that was it
you just prefer doing your own show and
getting out of there get my own show I'm
doing that I don't want to see nobody
I want to be involved in nothing
no group pictures no group pictures
I already did all that I paid my deuce
is it are you just trying to save time
like that's what every time I think
about like all the things you do
I just think of like wasting time and
you're like okay well I'm just gonna cut
out
all of the fat I wasted 30 years of my
[__] life
I got a second chance
do I look at the type of guy that has
time to waste [__] time
I wish I could get
15 of those dirty back
and I can't by staying healthy
sleeping resting planning out my
movements not getting [__] aggravated
not getting shot
avoid going somewhere with a Gunman's
going to come in and shoot like a
midnight showing a [__] Batman
okay with my kid okay
uh you just avoid the fat out of your
life
you know
I was strong enough for the certain age
I have a friend that I hung out with for
years
and okay the other day we're talking
about friendship okay okay it was this
was a very weird friendship we met in
Seattle
I like them
I like them but I realized something by
the third month
that he was a [__] a horrible liar
but as a friend I accepted that
you just lied about things yeah lie
about things lie about his dreams lie
about his
you know he was just the his experiences
and how they were and
but that was him I accepted him for him
and then he moved down here and I moved
down here and we were friends and
he opened this home to me
but
during that time I made observations
do you know what I'm saying of his
friendship and how he would talk in
different
things that he did and there was a time
when I wanted to throw him a beaten but
he had done something for me once he had
done something for me that was so
overwhelming
that not a lot of people would do
that I just gave him a life pass
what did he do he just did me a solid
okay let's just say he did me a real
solid what a guy would do
but the solid was that strong at that
time
so no matter what he did he accused me
of a couple things
he went behind me on a couple things now
I knew all these things
I knew all these things there was times
I get money and I throw him a little
Duke because he'd get mail for me at his
house for years I didn't like getting
mail where I live
why just in case
I don't want nobody knowing my address
so from 1990 would you come up with this
stuff so from 1990 to 2010 nobody really
knew my exact address
so I got my mail sent to his house
and my license was at his house
you follow me
yeah so I'd have to call him every day
and go over and get my [__]
and sometimes my [__] was open
from who he would open oh that's [__]
up and I couldn't say nothing
yes you could
and then he became something else he
quit his job
because he had gone to stupid Hollywood
parties
and he had heard this term and he wanted
to become one of those people
so he had worked on stupid projects
and he did that dumb job which whatever
he tell you his job was you'd find out
now he wasn't
like that's how bad of a liar he was
we knew other people that would get him
the job
and so he'd be like I'm the supervisor
but he was the best boy he was a busboy
we knew people at the same place
it just kept happening Lee
you know and here I am 10 12 years of
the sky and I thought that lying [__]
was gonna wear off
so that career that he told everybody he
was a big shot it failed so bad
it failed so bad that he got evicted
from his house
still hold on to his pride I never said
nothing to him
wasn't my business I played along with
the he wanted to leave
I had to go I got a job offer to be
involved with a huge project
up and wherever the [__] he was from
I was happy from he left it was then the
chapters in my mind I'm like this bomb
is never going to come back I don't
really have to deal with this [__] no
more
I'm down here fighting for my [__]
life it's 2008 there's about to be a
strike 2007. yeah 2008 2007 2007.
he's [__]
I'm on the phone
sorry about that people he's telling me
how he
uh is waiting for a check
and if the strike happens
he'll clear 750
000 on this next project
you know that he needs the strike to
happen and all this [__] and I swear to
Godly I got off the phone with him after
that conversation I'm like well this
guy's living
in his mother's basement
meanwhile I'm down here living in
Schrader addicted to blown banging it
out getting [__] movies and trying to
make moves and I'm on the phone with
some idiot
three thousand miles away trying to tell
me
in a place that the last thing they shot
there was a [__] mule they haven't
even shot a commercial in 200 years he's
trying to tell me he's involved in a
project that he's going to clear 750
thousand dollars
do you know I got off that phone at that
very moment I knew I was never going to
talk to that [__] anymore
yeah it was too negative you know why
because I don't have time for that [__]
no I'm trying to deal with real people
you know there was a timely
with this [__] phone used to ring 45
times a day that's my one that's my wife
go home one day when you come over I'm
gonna go to my wife go back to 2006.
what time would this phone start ringing
and one time with this solid
[__] let's try for another
bonogram that's right someone who's just
falling asleep at work monogram [__]
suck this is what happened I said
someone who's just falling asleep at
work just woke right up okay so there's
one time that your phone was ringing my
phone would ring at all while I was
doing that I remember when we first
started dating she sat me up one day
after like six months and she was like I
don't understand this lifestyle
people calling here calling you a
[__] was it the house phone or a
cell phone boat oh no the house oh
that's terrible you probably make her
answer the phone
oh yeah caller ID
so we know who was calling it was always
comics and
friends and not ages how did you get
anything done with 45 calls and it was a
lot of comedians
who used to call me and try to work me
what does that mean you know hey man
what's up Hey listen man I heard you in
this thing can you drop a headshot over
there for me and have it sit there and
go yeah and then I think about it and I
go how rude
yeah that always happens when like when
I when I was working on Hell's Kitchen
this girl that I hadn't like never spoke
one two word or two in high school
Facebook messaged me like hey I heard
you're in Hell's Kitchen can I can I
send you a video because she was like
she she wanted to be on the show
it's crazy and I one day I started going
off on people one by one
I just went by one like listen man I
can't do it like this weekend I got
three calls already for guest sets and
bro I don't wanna do guess that
I don't want to establish that quota
I'm doing it on Thursday for Tommy
Easter that's it I don't have guests
that's on the weekends
they pay money I don't want no guest
sets he's not gonna enhance the [__]
show you're not gonna answer by now you
just want to come down there and do
stupid [__] jokes and then bury me so
guess that's in my future never happened
at all
because I don't want to ask for guest
sets when I was pounding it out there I
wouldn't ask for guessets unless you
invited me unless you sworn me during
the week and said hey man what are you
doing Friday night I'm doing a show at
the Improv come do a [__] seven
minute guess after the MC
I would never ask
that's not even in my [__] world of
comprehension but
to get back to what you were saying
before
every year you learn me
and you start cutting fat let me tell
you something from 2000 and I kid you
not you know I tell you how it is like
from 2004 and you can ask Terry
from 2004
2008 league right I was going to three
maybe four lunches a week hearing
pictures
stories
me and people for coffee
I was open to anybody you know me
you got an idea
and I realized that half the people I
was meeting with wanted me to do the
work for them
and that's a horrible [__] feeling
how would you do the work for them as an
actor like fundraising and promoting and
stuff
I had people come to me from like when
Spider-Man 2 came out in Mad TV and I
had a couple of things come out but
nobody talked to me as a stand-up
for people always trying to put me on
bills as that actor
and then try to give me like 125 hours
and sit there and go how does this work
you know when you when I first moved to
Los Angeles the status quo was you got
on a TV show or you recurred
and because of that this is 98 97 99
2000 when you went to a local comedy
club people would come see you because
you had been on that TV show or you
hadn't been in that movie
that all changed when I started booking
movies you follow me Austin I started
booking movies ah that that that don't
work no more it's a new system yeah it's
a new phone credits didn't transfer so
it was just really weird a lot of people
want to shoot movies and use me
and I'm like so what does it pay
what oh you know oh my God
this is moving I met these guys for
no it's just I drove in Hollywood and I
was at the light and they used to be a
McDonald's then
and way before I met Lee Syed in 199
[__] eight when I got from 240 to 350
in six weeks
Terry Clark would make a tremendous
breakfast in those days and I would
shoot right from the house after smoking
pot and go to that McDonald's before 11
and get the Egg McMuffin packaged with
this coke and two apple pies for a
dollar
and across the street from there used to
be a a little [__] it's Hollywood
it's Sunset Boulevard
and uh Highland okay no the school is
still there Hollywood High I think it is
or something else is there there used to
be a Kenny Rogers
freezer there like a whatever it's not
there no more either I don't even know
what's there now it doesn't really
matter the story I'm trying to get to
was across the street from that guys was
a a place a theater
unless you [__] walked into that mall
parked your car and walked around people
you wouldn't know there was a theater in
there
like a movie theater yeah like a theater
where people go and watch plays on
one-man shows and whatever the guy that
owned the [__] theater was Joe
jerkoff
I get a call one day to go in there to
read for a [__] movie
you know agents get calls all the time
and they go okay Joe Diaz they look at
the paperwork the paperwork legit
decides
so I go down there I meet with the guys
I read
this guy's a big tough guy
at the first read and he says to me
listen
go home and learn this like in those
days I don't want to [__] like unless I
know the budget you know what I'm saying
because I don't want to go I don't want
to really go prepared I want to show you
that I could uh
react to Direction
okay so a lot of times
if it's in those days I was going to
read for a movie guys and it was four
auditions before I got the movie so the
first one's called the pre-read you read
one paragraph you meet the guy okay show
up next Thursday
so now you go from like a shitty theater
to next Thursday to a casting office
to the call back at the studio and
either Fox Warner Brothers or Sony you
know what I'm saying to the final read
at Sony
that's how the system was in those days
and what is it now
now they call you and say send the
[__] reel and we're putting you on a
veils from August 1st to the 19th
they've cut that in half because that's
just budgeting I got to pay those people
every step of the way you think Lee is
going to pre-read people for What
fighters no no Lee wants 200 a [__]
day to pre-read people
yeah like that it's expensive yeah it's
expensive so they cut out all those
steps
they just got the casting and said let
me see a list of your actors they
approve okay when you get these type of
rolls offer them [__] guest star
money and give them dates send us all
our tapes we'll judge people from tapes
they eliminated you even making the ride
down there no do they do that for like
the bigger rolls because like my
question is could you stop accepting the
roles that aren't paying you what you
want and only go out for those big roles
I did I stopped doing hunting all day
movies 265 whatever 44. I don't want to
do them I'm even saying now because you
because you were saying you like even
now you come to me you come to me
tomorrow and you go listen I wrote a
[__] script okay read it if you like
it call me back okay I'm not even I'm
gonna look at you and go can I ask you
personal questions is there a budget
you're gonna go there is but I want you
to read and call me back
because I want you to call me and tell
me that you Bri you wrote a script
but you wrote a a character that I put
play and I understand and the character
understands me I know I sound [__] but
I'm just getting to something no it
could be a I could be a butcher
that whatever I could do a lot of
[__] dumb [__]
if I read this script and knocks my
pants off and I say to you hold on one
second who's playing this role and who's
playing that bro
and you say to me James Woods is playing
in this room there's no big star he's a
character actor that nobody would pay
money to go watch in a movie if you put
him in a big movie he's great right but
you're not gonna put James Woods as the
as the actor to go watch not usually
yeah no so okay so
can you say Jane you know I've done a
thousand hundred mile Day movies with
actors that are great actors
you know the guy from Deer Hunter James
Russo I've done a lot of great movies
with guys that you've seen and go wow
why is that guy doing a whole all day
movie because they're probably giving
him 350 a day and they give him six days
it's nineteen two thousand dollars
without overtime that fills in the gaps
for those guys
in between the big movies
right no I understand and I and I
understand that you have to take other
roles right but you if you wanted to
stop getting those small rolls could you
just do those bigger roles have
auditions or are they just giving yeah
sometimes there's auditions and you go
meet with the director and the producer
and the star of the movie
you know I've gone to a thousand movies
when I I've walked in the room and
there's a casting director a producer
and John Travolta or [__] the other
guy or or you know I've been in those
situations
it's a shocking situation yeah when you
first walk because they don't tell you
uh really no they're not going to tell
you it's your Vault it's going to be in
the room or Johnny Bananas is going to
be in the room at least I had they don't
tell your dick they go you're gonna go
in there and read for the casting
director
that's the first time and the second
time there might be a producing the room
then the third time they want to see the
chemistry
to dudes in the [__] room yeah that
makes sense the dudes in the room they
want to see the [__] chemistry I'm
about to spend a lot of money yeah they
want to see the chemistry in those High
land that's why they call those screen
tests
that's why they call those big TV shows
like ABC now they're picky NBC those
networks are looking for a specific look
well and they make you go in there and
read and it's a [__] nightmare I I
saw uh Gabriel's doing his new show
right now and a while you'll he
instagramed a picture that Martin had to
audition to be himself in the show right
that's crazy no you have to it's it they
don't give a [__] it's like the Seinfeld
joke yeah there's no more yo you're
coming in here but
the question you asked him it was what
how do we even [__] get to this [__]
huh oh no it's just about choosing the
audition to go out on choosing the
auditions you're going on but this
[__] dude I haven't stopped talking
to him and one of the reasons why I
stopped talking to him honest to God
was because of time
I started chopping away at time
people go to me Jesus Joy where did you
come from I've been doing comedy for 25
years this June
I started using my time correctly around
10 years ago
and that's when I started becoming a
comic
I've told you a thousand times
I know a thousand people who don't have
jobs but they're always busy
because they managed the time
they wake up at six and from seven to
ten you'll catch them doing something
that's three good hours then you know
one at 10 they'll take a ride to go to a
library
to go to a martial arts class to work
out
then they'll go back to work it's
control
it's a waste of time it's what you do
with your time when I was just going to
the economy store and writing jokes in
the car to The Comedy Store that's what
I got from Comedy
but when I started sitting down and
writing stories and actually wow going
man wait a second I should take that
[__] out of there and replace it with a
[__] or throw that joke out that's when
comedy
flourished for me
that just doesn't happen in comedy
that's gonna happen with Paula when she
becomes a lawyer that happens when
you're a dentist that happens when you
work for yourself and you're an artist
time management is the most important
thing that's been the hardest part for
me okay you start thinking about why am
I meeting this jerk off for coffee
this is my Prime Time money area
if I'm not writing if I'm not picking up
an envelope I'm writing
what am I writing I got 10 things to
write a book
a [__] TV show and a special
so
unless we're doing something as
spectacular
it's enough
it's a no
and I stick to my guns
but I've done that all alone with comedy
except I started chopping it little by
little
if you're a new guy and you come to me
right now what were we talking about
lately when we were talking about the
honor protein powder
what was the key word we spoke about
lifestyle oh yeah lifestyle change
lifestyle that's what happens to people
they become Comics they try to become a
comedian but they can't adjust to their
lifestyle change
you gotta start telling people no
and it goes away from your mind
it disappears from your mind and I have
a problem I always assume those people
are going to get mad but they never
really do nobody gets mad everybody
understands no is no
there's a thing where there's a lie
there's a thing that's called the brutal
lie what does that mean a brutal eye is
I can't do this no more with you
with you I I can't afford you and
I just can't do this no more with you I
think I'm Gonna Cancel the church
and you wait two weeks you'll get
another thing job and listen I'm doing
the church with somebody else
that's a brutal lie
it's a brutal lie
this happened that happened this is why
it's a brutal lot yeah and these things
are called White Lies that hurt no one
hey what are you doing September 26th
I'm getting married in the Bahamas
uh Joe Diaz has a show
well I looked at his website it's not oh
it's on there it's on there you just
haven't looked close enough you know I
don't go on the road with joy but for
some reason that week he wants me to go
with him yeah
Paul is sitting there watching TV eating
popcorn looking at you like
you know
that's a white lie
these are business reasons
you just don't choose
to go to the Bahamas on the 26th with
somebody's wedding
and you don't want to ask is there a
cruise are you paying for the cruise on
the way down there are you paying for
the hotel because somewhere along the
line this is going to cost you money
ton of money and a ton of money and you
don't really have time for nine days
you're in the middle of a podcast you're
trying to do the podcast with the girls
you work in your Consulting business so
what are you telling me
I can't I don't have time
they freak out come on what do you mean
you don't have time for me Joey Diaz
we've been friends for 20 years
let me talk to Paula she's great yeah
you know it's [__] so hard to explain
yourself to people sometimes
so sometimes you have to say a white lie
sometimes and people
it's business
it's [__] business
sometimes Lee I don't have the time to
explain to you
annoy you well enough to say you know
what my daughter gets caught sick on the
way [__] down there
I can't take you down you know what I'm
saying like I don't have time I don't
know you that well
right you know after a certain age you
start thinking out the mood before it
happens
hey what are you doing next weekend me
and some friends are going to San Diego
and we want to see if you want to go
down there we're going to leave on
Thursday on the train also you start
doing the math
in your head you started thinking about
it right there as they're telling you
time yeah wait a second that means I
gotta pack I gotta cancel work on Friday
I got a [__] pack I gotta get
somebody who wants the cats
I got a [__] uh and who am I staying
with well we're all gonna share rooms
you know we're gonna three people in the
room that means I gotta smell somebody's
thoughts and here's somebody talking all
night long and somebody's gonna get
drunk in the room all I want to do is do
blow and get my dick sucked I'm very
happy why am I why am I dropping 800 to
go to San Diego I'm not gonna get my
dick sucked I'm gonna be in a room with
two other people
and I can stay home safe 400 slow Nate
Ball by myself maybe the neighbor come
over and lick my balls if I want to take
a chance Columbus did
that sometimes you make a [__] you
know where this is gonna go
and you know yourself
at a certain age one day you go [__] it
I know myself
this is what I really want to [__] do
and it never is like all those vacations
that you really plan
always seem to have something go wrong
like the really over plan vacations like
those and especially I hate going on
those trips where people are sharing
rooms because then people are like
splitting bills at restaurants weirdly
and they don't it's it just listen
I don't know what I want to do
hmm
until when listen I gotta get up
tomorrow and go to Bray I know that for
sure
okay that's for sure that's a positive
I know I gotta pick my wife up tomorrow
that's a positive that plane might be
late there's going to be severe weather
in Chicago and [__] Paducah [__]
there's gonna be bad weather in Texas
tomorrow all across the [__] Iowa is
the whole [__] deal
I got that going on
I got radio in the morning
but between [__] 11 and five I really
have nothing much going on if my wife
cancels and flying or whatever the [__]
you know that's my time that's my time
to choose
so I leave that open I'm gonna see how I
feel
if I'm swelling from Jiu Jitsu today
maybe I won't do kettlebells tomorrow
but if I'm not you follow me if I'm not
sure I'll do cattle bus I don't know
what's gonna really crack to the morning
you know what I'm not gonna call it 9am
they're going for an audition at 12 15
tomorrow
for a big time [__] movie
that's always everyone always can never
understand when they call me and they're
like how many times this week and I'm
like I I don't know how many times have
I called you and I've talked to you
nobody knows nothing
I don't know nothing yeah
I don't know nothing I don't know
nothing until tomorrow morning
because it changes I've I've
sat there till seven and shut the
[__] phone off at seven
and got back to the phone at 10 and I
got three missed calls from a [__]
agent
or three messages from an agent
because nobody else leaves me messages
just you know
just the agents I remember when we were
shooting or getting ready to shoot the
documentary like your wife put me
through like a Joey Diaz boot camp like
every time I started to like ask a
question or like try to clarify a date
or something no she'd be like no no we
don't know nothing we don't know we
don't know nothing until the day of and
it's funny because people contact you in
plans and agendas I don't know nothing
hit me up hey man I'm a big fan I just
want you to know that when you come to
Buffalo
uh I love to be a driver
I want you to come over and eat then
listen why are you bothering me Buffalo
is five weeks away
I'm not even worried about Buffalo right
now Buffalo is not even on my [__]
radar even if I wanted it to be
I'm worried about Brea I'm not even
worried about Monday
I don't know what my why who knows
Hey Joe what are we doing next week I
have no idea
yeah
I have a rough schedule in my mind but
no one gets to see that one but now it's
loose
it's very loose
I'm a little sore I took on a leaf
you know I gotta do radio in the morning
I gotta shoot out of the [__] house
early tomorrow
all right I don't have my car right I'm
driving my wife's car so I haven't had
the phone in the car I don't drive with
the [__] phone in the car
I just don't even put it on right
because why pick it up and give a ticket
I get pissed when I see people driving
with a [__] phone so I don't pick up
my [__] phone you know if I'm in my
car I'll Bluetooth it but then my wife I
don't know how to Bluetooth
I don't touch nothing because I don't
know if I want to break it you get these
people to get in your car and start
touching things next thing you know you
put your car on you got Opera in Chinese
and you get you know what the [__] is
this [__] are you listening to try
anything no but I've had that people
come in my car and they touch [__] don't
touch nothing I don't touch nothing in
your [__] car you know what I put the
radio on if that's not the music I don't
want I just shut the radio off right now
no I go deep into my thoughts we got
thoughts I go deep into my [__]
thoughts I don't have time people come
in your car every time my wife touches
my Comics you know I get in the car I
bust my knee because it's a [__] seat
I don't even I fill in there but my leg
goes I break my [__] ankle
one day I'm gonna break my [__] ankle
in the goddamn car I don't touch nothing
I don't do nothing I
don't know
and guess what I don't want to know
nothing I don't want to know
I don't know and I don't I don't know
most importantly I think with you I
don't know and I don't [__] wanna
know I don't know I have no idea what
I'm doing July 12th but you know what I
really don't care and I really don't
care what you're doing it's not like I
wouldn't be surprised when Davey just
got a call on here and just left I've
been stressing out lately I don't know
if you know like last week I was in Hell
last week what can I ask why I was in
Hell last week because I had to take
this trip with my wife to [__]
whatever and then
well I got on the plane
listen I fly for a living not only on a
plane to go somewhere if only go
somewhere take a picture send it to me I
don't want to go nowhere all right I
don't want to say nothing
so but save this damn because I don't
want to know I've been getting eaten
alive somebody invited me to their
wedding
and my wife told me you know what you
gotta talk to him you know the date
and then the person called me and I said
listen man listen I'm gonna tell you
something right off the bat because I'm
I can't lie to them I can't give them a
white line so listen
I suffer from extreme [__] anxiety
you know what that means that's a new
type of anxiety I invented that means if
something bothers me I start yelling and
screaming and [__] like a [__] I don't
know nothing I don't want to sit and all
right so I told her I said here's the
deal
you gotta pick one and she goes what are
you talking about oh you gotta pick one
and she goes what do you mean I go it's
either the church or the party
she goes you won't come to both I go you
want me to lie to you I'll tell you the
truth
and she goes why not and she goes I was
going to invite you to the
the dinner
that's not gonna happen
that's not gonna happen that's the
rehearsal Friday night that's never
gonna happen
the only way I go to rehearsal it's the
chance dragon
I broke it down just like that
for anyone's wedding I don't give a [__]
no I'm saying like if it was like
someone can you will you go to one in
another together I could talk to them we
grew up together okay so I said the only
way I'll go to this rehearsal tonight if
we go to change dragon
and I heard silence just like the way
you look at me right now so I know that
wasn't gonna fly and she goes why not
and I go because I'm not into that [__]
I'll sit there and it drives me crazy
after 20 minutes I gotta go
I gotta go what do you want I gotta go I
gotta get out of here
I don't give a [__] I don't give a [__]
what you I don't care if a truck with
lasagna that means nothing to me I want
spare ribs
the only thing that'll calm me down and
make me listen to all these people and
their stupid stories
it's if I got an egg roll and asparagus
I could just look at them and smile and
shake my head up and down like I give a
[__] while I'm eating the [__] when I'm
dipping this [__] Egg Roll in the
mustard you understand me I'll sit there
and look at you and not in my head sure
yeah fight free right whatever
yes I'm gonna die yeah oh yes
[Music]
oh
yeah yes people that
sometimes
what is this noise I sit here every
night it sounds like the [__] train
The Godfather I'm supposed to shoot you
and go outside what is this [__]
noise that we got there must have a
flight schedule directly over what time
is it
where's it coming in from [__] NASA
this is amazing
so that that's it I just don't like
doing none of that shitly
I wasn't raised that way I like being a
free spirit I can't commit to a date
you want me to get on the plane and not
pick up an envelope I gotta go and see a
palm tree I don't want to see a palm
tree I've seen enough palm trees I live
right I got a palm tree on my block
I do I got a nice palm tree on my black
I go down there see a golf I don't want
to play golf
I like exactly how it's done no what
what are you gonna say to parents who
say Well when mercy gets older you're
gonna have to be on some sort of a
schedule
I have one on the schedule I don't mind
her schedule I'll do whatever the [__]
she needs to do that's a completely
different game she needs to go oh she
can be on the schedule but yeah oh yeah
for her I'll make my schedule around huh
because I enjoy her company yes so
you're gonna look like are you gonna go
to like soccer games and all that stuff
if I'm in town [__] yeah that's gonna be
so much fun if listen I want to be a
part of that I have plans a man without
a plan is not a man I enjoy going on the
road I enjoy writing the [__] jokes
but you know what the flight's back is
starting to [__] kill me
and the dizzy spells I get when I
[__] drive I get [__] car sick
I've been good this week so I'm doing
something right I haven't got car sick
all this week I also haven't been up and
down Laurel Canyon
so okay I got on that I went to Ventura
didn't get car sick went to Oxnard
didn't get caught sick drove all the way
down to 405 didn't get [__] caustic
so I'm doing something right maybe maybe
take the 101 to The Comedy Store now try
that I gotta go all the way around
that's too much mileage but you gotta
leave seriously when I started
respecting my time right when I started
making big movements in my life okay
when I started handling my time one
thing about me is I love getting up
early since I was in the fifth grade
once I got left back I want to do
everything on my own but I did
everything on my own I like doing
everything on my [__] own except like
this week I almost burnt the house down
twice and Galilee was here one time I
left the stove on the other time I left
the [__] oven on I left the back door
open
I'm a mess I can't be around those
animals I feel so bad I had to feed them
and hug them and [__] they're living
like what the [__] is going on my
mother's been gone for a week you got to
respect your time uh
Rogan has a big it's a big time guy the
big time guys they have time Mitch
Hedberg really taught me the the
importance of time
you can [__] light Mitch hedberg's
door on fire when he lived on
cerebellned it from 8 to 12. Mitch
Hedberg wrote every day and he would not
and there was no phone there was nothing
there was no radio there was nothing but
that's what worked for him
he respected that time and there was a
comic years ago his name was Corey
Miller they called him zoom in I don't
even know I think he shortened at the
zoo because they tried to sue him zoo
man came out here Corey Miller and got a
big time deal and I became friends with
him he's a very good looking dude he's
still around doing College is very funny
talented to the [__] end of time but
one thing I learned about him in 1999
was that he wrote something seven days a
week every day was something different
like a different subject different
subject poetry on Monday even though he
wasn't a poet he read his poetry he was
no poet but he tried that wasn't his
interpretation of poetry for how long
Tuesday he wrote comedy Wednesday he
wrote a screenplay Thursday he wrote a
book Friday he wrote comedy he locked
himself in a room for three hours a day
he wrote his own script he took it to
ABC they didn't pick it up he took his
money he left but he did the steps A to
Z on his own and his discipline was the
writing and guess what just because he
was doing it guess what Lee I wasn't
doing it
did you why weren't you doing it
because I was lazy I was addicted to
drugs so I thought that my system was
better and yes I was a naturally funny
guy but there was no content you know
what I'm saying all I had to do was
write a story of my life at that point
and we would have the ball rolling
do you think you being naturally funny
held you back
yes it made me very lazy at times
it made me lazy after I got into the
store I think about all those years
it made me very lazy because I knew I
could go up there and smoke and mirror
them now at least I'm giving them
something I'm giving them something
about myself I'm leaving something up
there
and they're getting it you know what I'm
saying which I want to switch it up on
this next tour you follow me I really
want to switch it up that's why I've
been hibernating just
trying new [__] you know you have to
evolve when I was on mma's podcast
yesterday we talked to Evolution I
learned a lot from MMA from evolving
speaking of MMA something happened this
week that people in Shaka
you know and we need to talk about it
because a lot of people ask me about
this you know uh
the email numbers have been going down
for the last six or seven weeks they
went from being 90 emails a week 70
emails the week to 40. okay but the
subject the main subject I was looking
at this Monday afternoon when I was
answering emails
the main subject still is people trying
to get their [__] together
and how it starts and it starts with a
plan
and there's a way to do it and there's a
way not to do it because there's
different situations of getting your
[__] together
and they're sitting out we've discussed
how many times I got in trouble as a
young man and how much police contact I
had as a man I could look you straight
in the eye really the only disdain I
ever had for a police officer was for
the police officer who was in charge of
my case in Boulder
which one was that
his name was David something well um uh
which case was it the kidnapping case
the public case because he really
believed that he was doing something
and he wasn't doing anything you know
what I'm saying like he really believes
somewhere that he was doing something
for the community or something
why do you think he wasn't because
he didn't know he's just a tool in
society
that for every Joey Diaz you put away
there's 19 more coming your way and
there's nothing you could do yeah but he
still has to do that he still has to do
it but the way he acted doing the whole
thing like he acted like [__] uh Adam
12 okay but anyway that was the only cop
but in that whole
18-month experience I never listened my
voice that much
just didn't talk to him which really
[__] him up
the only time I talked to him was the
day of my arrest
and then he would come they'd send
investigators to talk to me and I said
you got to talk to my attorney
I wouldn't talk to him
and then when we go to court he tried to
address me and [__]
and I wouldn't even look at the
[__] and part of the reason why
I was because he was looking for me for
a different case and I didn't want him
to look at me and [__] remember that
he was looking for me for a different
case at the time but that's not the the
thing of the story I never disrespected
him
in fact the district attorney in the
case I bumped into him at the
supermarket a couple times
I ain't gonna lie to nobody the first
time I bumped into the second and third
time
I creeped up on him you follow me
because I wanted to talk to him and my
relationship with him was great in fact
those conversations we had reduced his
sentence by three [__] years
because he got to know the real me
I told you reduced it by three years I
lived it I saw him
I saw it happen I saw him drop for nine
years and eight
the four to six and then they gave me
four it was his call
I'm telling you this right now
sometimes man like with club Owners now
I have an agent that talks to club
Owners but sometimes I call him on the
side
and talk to him because I want them to
know I'm a human being that's very
important to me
so I wanted this district attorney to
know that I wasn't just a person on a
piece of paper and a mugshot
I wanted him to talk to me it was
important so I just went up on him one
day like what was happening
and he's like you live around here I go
yeah I live around the corner
like what are we going to do with this
case man you know I'm a good guy and
he's like he started going listen man
first off I shouldn't be talking to you
and I'm like listen forget about that
talk to me
I'm a human being talk to me I [__] up
but what I what you're saying I did and
what I did is two different stories
guess who was [__] up at that time it
was mainly
I didn't see it from his point of view
and his point of view was correctly I
didn't see it as that extreme it was
extreme and by him sending me to prison
he was sending saving my life
he wanted me to know that what I did at
that time me pulling the gun on you was
what we did
that's what I was aspiring to do so I
thought it was fine you were you were
inspiring I was sparring to pull guns on
people so I understood
but the moral of the story is that I
didn't really ever have a beef I got
arrested in New York a couple times I
got arrested in Jersey a couple times I
got to rest in Colorado a couple times I
got arrested in Miami once a couple
times I got arrested in Seattle a couple
times and there was really never an
altercation with a police officer in
fact it was always it always ended with
thank you and I'm sorry for you having
to do this and no no it's my job and
that type of [__] I watched the Jon
Jones thing the other day
and I could hear that disdain and this
voice of the the cop I mean they don't
like him you follow me they don't like
them from the other thing already they
know his vehicles
right but what he doesn't understand is
what John was saying the other day Mr
John McCarthy was saying that you don't
have to drag race to actually drag race
it's revving your engine
that's drag racing That's the Law so
with all this aside
uh I've had a lot of people contact me
and asked me a top subject that that has
always
intrigued me
since I was a young [__] guy I was
around it
was that
and I watched how it worked
okay
it's a thing called probationally
and probation could be a real good thing
or it could be a really [__] bad
thing
let me tell you why it's a really bad
because you gotta walk on eggshells
and he's not gonna walk on eggshells no
the reason why they give you probation
is because of the percentage Factor
they already know
the percentage
of you getting arrested
they already know
that's why they agreed to it first off
as a human being to a human being here
I'm a fan of Jon Jones I love John Jones
yeah he's great I knew John as a human
being before he became a champion I used
to talk to him at the fights and giggle
with them because tripoli's from the
same Hometown and I used to drop 607 or
whatever 706 and giggle with them
and I gotta tell you he's a sweetheart
of a [__] guy I did not know as an as
a fan or whatever that he did blow I did
not know about this
I had heard Rumblings and then that
thing went down
real quick after I heard the Rumblings
the car crash the car crash went down
and then I heard more Rumblings and I
just saw his behavior in different
situations and I'm talking to you people
as a Coke addict
you follow me I'm not talking to you as
some [__] guy that owns a rehab here
that's trying to sell you on psychology
I'm talking to you on the [__] the
reels of this situation here
when he ran away his but all that stuff
you know uh
you didn't even go to rehab he didn't
stay the 30 days all those little things
are warning signs
and it affects the D.A the D.A knows
your frame I thought by you doing that
the D.A is saying this guy's not
claiming responsibility
and I told you guys on this show before
on rogans when you don't claim
responsibility at that point you're
never going to claim it it's going to
come back to bite you in the ass if you
don't check on your skeletons from time
to time they're gonna check up on you
and they checked up on me for 20 [__]
years Lee that's why I'm talking to you
about experience in this [__] right so
when somebody gives you probation let's
say you get a year probation
a [__] could do year probation
right but
it takes
a slick [__] you gotta okay
because some probations they're not
gonna test you for THC
we don't want you bloodly we don't want
none we don't want you pissed we don't
want nothing we're not even going to
come to the house what we want you to do
is come into the office
bring us your pay stubs part of the
condition is you do 16 hours of
community service in that year
Because unless you do the community
service you're not going to end with
probation they're going to bring you
back to court and violate you
so do that [__] community service you
go on the guide you get that over with
because the quicker you get that over
with the quicker you complete your case
if I'm a good attorney I might be able
to get you off on a six-month probation
on deferred sentence
but you can't do ugots
nothing you can't get a [__] parking
violation
so the first thing I got to tell Jon
Jones is why is he out late at night
right with a [__] 200 000 car I'm not
sure if that's the price tag on the call
do not quote me I don't know nothing
about [__] cars
but I think it's another example of
saving time because he's on probation
he's about to have a fight
stop right there okay he's on probation
but the big thing is all eyes are on him
yeah that forget the fight but he's
breaking before he has a fight coming up
the water probation
before anything
all eyes are upon
it all eyes are upon
it yeah he's a big investment for the
UFC
and he's fighting next time
he should be people like so he should
have a driver and what driver are you
talking about
your own probation
the only time you're out of your house
when you're on probation it's called
sunlight to sun down
that's the only way you're ever gonna
make it on probation
that's 50 of it right there I know a lot
of you people looking at me going Joey
wouldn't agree with you we'll take a
chance Columbus did [__]
you will end up in jail because I'm
cutting your evil percentages out
completely
nobody who listens to this podcast if
you ever get in trouble God forbid
you're going to get in trouble in the
daytime unless you get a parking ticket
or you get pulled over for a ticket
when you go pick up weed it's at night
when you go pick up blow it's at night
when you get into a fist fight it's at
night at a bar
so do you understand me the only way
probation works is for you to look at
the mirror and go
um I'm never going out at night again
not to a movie
maybe to a dinner with my wife
and that's it and I'm gonna and I'm
gonna pick my route when I drive
especially when all eyes are upon me
and he's because most people are
listening to this going Joey what the
[__] are you saying
Liam I tell you
I did it
I did it I took out my nightlife
completely
check it out at one point I knew the
only way I could beat my nightlife ended
it ended probably when I got to Colorado
but I still thought I was Johnny machine
guns and I would go out at night from
time to time to clubs
and well I mean from time to time but I
cut everything like I used to even get
my Coke in the daytime and hide it for
the night time
do you understand me like this is what
I'm talking about
this is the discipline that takes about
probation huh that's how you survive
probation
the only reason why I [__] up on
was because of my high urine test yeah I
used to give a hot urine test
but afterward after I got out of the
halfway house I was on probation they
put me on a long [__] probation
and after I did a year I took it back to
a judge and they signed me off oh cool
and that year to me was not rough by no
means
I knew what my percentage was
I still did Coke
I still smoke dope
but I went and got it at lunch time
okay
you gotta do different things at
different times I never ever
ever went out that year
ever I went from my job straight to my
[__] house
straight to my [__] house
I worked at Boulder Toyota at the time
I didn't make much money I made maybe 28
to 3200 a month and it was just it was a
store people came in they had good
credit you have to do credit checks on
them they [__] lived in Boulder all
their lives
you knew where you stood you sold 10 to
12 cars a month
nobody broke your balls they didn't give
you a demo they didn't drug test you
you could smoke dope in the back
everybody smoked dope there I had a nice
job there but I swear to my [__]
daughter I went from the job straight to
the [__] house
because your percentages of going to buy
coke will go higher
I knew this
this is why they still haven't been
[__] jail right now
I'm in jail till tomorrow morning
and that's when the [__] hit the fan
that's when they decide because listen
to me they gave him a big break up front
do you understand me when they give you
a big break up front
they're just waiting now
everybody looked at that [__] video
you don't think that they unless UFC's
gonna be able to pay off the judge and
be like hey man this is the second
[__] violate this is the first
violation
they gave him a big breather now a lot
of people at home going well Joey he
wasn't drag racing maybe he could listen
a lot of you get tickets a lot of you
people don't act like the right way no
no nobody who listens to this podcast
has called the cop a [__] liar and a
pig
and the guy didn't [__] smack him
which you know because he's Jon Jones I
would have caught if I'm a cop I could
the guy didn't call eight other cops the
guy knew he was on camera
because that's why I came out the body
camera came out yeah no no [__]
everybody know they're on a [__]
camera but he could also [__] call
for eight other cars to come
and they could have pulled Jon Jones out
of the car and asked him if he was
drinking or if he had something in the
car
that night
that was a big [__] shot that night
that was very big that night but if you
look at it from that annual
I never thought about it that way but
yeah I can see what you're saying there
it's listen I'm telling you that the bad
things happen at night Chris Rock said
nobody goes to an ATM machine at two in
the morning to do something good right
nobody goes at two in the morning and
that's the truth same rule applies when
I was a kid I used to go to Miami
and my uncle on Miami was on probation
another man telling me it's son to son
and I go what does that mean he goes
after once the sun drops
I don't leave the house I don't do that
I will let you leave the house he goes
they let me do what I want
I don't leave the house
because what's the why
waste for one party for one bad dinner
why waste another six years in jail or
whatever well no no no no that's not
gonna happen to you bad things happen
when you're in a bar if I put you on
probationally you know what's gonna
happen one night I'm gonna tell you
what's gonna happen one night you're
gonna go out with Joe Diaz okay in the
old days You're Gonna hook up with Joe
Diaz he's going to invite you over to
some [__] Irish bar on [__]
Magnolia
you're gonna sit there with Joe Diaz
here you are on probation Joe Diaz three
other jerk offs some [__] [__] girl
you had some bar drinking
you know or why am I here next thing you
know a fight breaks out the cops come in
I give you the coke to hold
as you're walking out the door they pull
you over search you and hear you do got
a gram in your pocket that ain't even
yours you're just doing a felony favor
that's how quick this [__] happens on
probation or
there is a fight
you come to my help you pull me off the
guy
the guy pushes me I bump into you you
push the guy
as you're walking away the cops come in
that's a violation
what's the violation you pulling me off
that fight because right now the cops
were walking and they go so who are you
my name is Lisa ahead
and what happened here and the guy's
gonna go he pushed me I didn't push you
[__] you hit my friends and I pushed
you to get you off him you just admitted
yourself what happened in front of the
cop so the cop has to write this in this
[__] report now let's say the cop is
a great guy
and he goes everybody get the [__] out
of here he still has some submit that
report there's five cops there
somebody's gonna notice you're on
probationally
and they're gonna call you and they're
gonna go can you come into my office
they're gonna read reports yeah
you have to assume you have to assume in
today's age with the computers and [__]
once they process that stuff
I did I thought no one read those things
you never [__] know
it happened to me I got arrested and got
a PV on the reason why I have a [__]
born in Seattle is because I got
involved at the [__] fight at the
club
and you're on probation and I was on
probation
and the cops came and didn't give me a
summons but they wrote up the report so
three days later Seattle violated me for
the [__] police coming at the [__]
Comedy Club oh my God that's [__]
that's crazy that's like a red light
camera so they came they arrested me and
threw me in jail no bail until I went in
front of a judge the judge let me out
blah blah blah blah blah blah
here we are 20 [__] years later
so those probation violations aren't no
[__] joke he's in jail till tomorrow
[__] morning
no money could get you out no attorney
could get you out it's like getting
busted in New York with a gun you don't
make bail it's 18 months it's that
[__] whatever law the Brady Law
whatever the [__] it is
and he hasn't even harder because he's
you were saying all eyes are on him
always on him because he's him but he's
he's a star athlete so he already he is
already basically on probation and then
now he's on
extra legal probation now he's racing
and he shouldn't he shouldn't let if
he's saying he wasn't racing but he said
the fans were being mean to him or
something so even if they were just roll
up your windows and like oh I didn't I
didn't know nothing about fans baby let
me look to him let me look at it all I
seen was [__] him in the car uh
talking like that to the cop and reading
today he got arrested that's all I know
all I know is he got [__] pulled
overly okay well the fans were mean to
him or whatever it's my point what the
[__] are you doing at what time was it
when he was out
let's see what time it was tell me what
time it was
does anybody know
let me check that's the most important
thing let's pretend he was out at 9 30
he went to get [__] in milk for his
kids
even then that's what I'm trying to tell
you you got to make your moves in the
[__] daytime
because everything bad happens at night
people go
let's pretend it was 9 28 at night on a
[__] Friday night
okay
that's how [__] crucial I'm telling
you 10 a.m he turned himself in at 10 am
no I know what time he turned himself in
what time did the incident happen on
[__] Friday night or Saturday night
oh Jesus Christ I didn't say anything
you say I deal with people let me give
some shout outs real quick here and get
this [__] party rolling here I'll
look it up for after this yeah that
Squad Charlotte you know Jimmy Pitts I
love you spooky Louis zumad Freddie
Correa up there holding it down the
comedy
bad [__] over there in Las Vegas
Josh
pitway Diana Mateo and my man Pat Shay I
wish you a lot of luck Bob lingus's dad
is at home recovering and uh my brother
from another mother Larry [__] boom
boom
the security agent my family happy
birthday is his birthday in two days
talking land on Twitter
yeah what time did the incident occur
that's what's the most important thing
to me
yeah I'm trying to find you know and
he's out there with his [__] uh a
million dollar car already people are
[__] hating on you you know you just
hit somebody in a [__] car
you're in like a Volvo or something like
a family car that nobody's even looking
at you you know
these are the little things that you got
to clean up when you're trying to put
your life together because people look
at those [__] things it's like the
7-5 when they told them don't bring the
[__] Corvette to the station right
they brought the Corvette to the station
you're just gonna irritate the [__] out
of people
okay here it is probably
[__]
[__] you don't know what the [__] it
is anyway don't man I don't know I can't
find it no nobody's gonna find it that's
the that's the thing with probation that
I never liked
they're gonna give you a probation might
as well do the 90 days
say [__] give me the 90 [__] days
and then you can just be off of a two
years 90 days and you're out of the
situation did you ever do that a few
times I tried and why didn't you they I
tried to [__] go to work release when
I got sentenced that time
they told me that that Monday before the
Friday they go well we could hope for is
two things
120 days of Community Corrections and
then probation
or 90 days work release
I'm like I'll do [__] work on this
and they were like it's not up to you
it's up to the [__] judge the judge
like was when we said Work Release he
just he he threw cold water and he
didn't even react to it
he was like you know I don't know 90
days so which one did you get the I got
the six years in prison
oh it was at that point yeah yeah yeah
yeah oh you could have just gone 90 days
I was hoping see I was hoping that was
the best result possible in my world
but I was going to get
uh
120 days work release I was already
enrolled at the University of Colorado I
was in the ceop program
they're like come on you didn't have to
do they're like give the kid a break he
enrolled
he's already in the [__] thing he's
part of something they gave him a second
chance you might as well gain the second
chance so we kept up playing that angle
so we were like there's hope we're gonna
go in there and flip them we're gonna go
in there and flip them right in the
courtroom we're gonna flip him he's
gonna go [__] it 120 days work release
six years probation
then we're going to do a year probation
straight up and then when I go back to
court and cut the probation out that was
the initial plan
and the judge just didn't want you to do
that no Community Corrections turned me
down
Community Corrections has two different
levels they have the halfway house and
they control the county jail
and they vote so both of them voted and
said [__] no we don't want that
[__] is the person they're
voting on your future
like a board there's a board like a
board of three
so both of them voted me out
so now we were going to try to get the
judge to override everybody
and say you've got to take this
[__] in there that was our only
hope and prayer on Monday morning
okay what happened they sent me to jail
instead there was no [__] even hope
he didn't even consider he was like [__]
you no way
no way
which when I looked at his face I knew
the [__] alternative when I just said
that to you right now I could just see
his little [__] squirrely face he was
a good dude though he was small and he
had a beard he just looked like he was
just one big [__] Bush or you could
see were his eyes and his mouth he just
had a beard in his face and it was small
and
when he looked at the paperwork and he
kept looking at me and looking at that
paperwork and looking at me and I
[__] knew it
looking back on it did you ever really
have a chance at any of those other
options or no you were going to jail I
was going to jail in my mind
in my delusional cocaine mind I was
gonna beat the case all together
if you had gone to them and just said
hey get the deals that you actually
ended up with and didn't do all that
other legal stuff from now your legal
fees would have been like right now if I
would have known what I know now then
that's exactly what I would have done
okay telling you right now I would have
gotta on bail number one
number two I would accommend myself to a
90-day rehab
and came out and played the [__] the
role of the [__] rehab guy
and I've been probation investigation I
would have said that it was my [__]
fault I would have copped to the whole
thing
I would have come to the whole thing in
my probation investigation
what and just and to say no guilty
please you planned the whole thing no
then I knew exactly what I was doing
that the cocaine led me there
I would have blamed it along the [__]
Coke that would have been the weasel Joe
Diaz at that time
I would have said I would have done 90
days in the rehab came out gone to AAA
for a month
[__] them off just got fake signatures
did all the [__] I used to stupid [__] I
used to do then
and then uh I would never [__] learn
my lesson
instead of doing what I did I went to a
rehab and got off easy because I
wouldn't have really adjusted to the
rehab I would have bullshitted them to
him eventually
I would have just learned how to get off
the blow like I did when I went into
prison when I got locked up I didn't do
blow in there
I adjusted my life not to have it I got
it out of my mind I knew it wasn't gonna
happen
and that was it it didn't really stop
the addiction it just made the addiction
grow just because you're not doing the
drug your addiction's still grown we
discussed this
really so so you the whole time even
though you weren't doing the person you
wanted it wanted what Coke no I didn't
say that
I didn't say that I said that I knew in
my mind I wasn't gonna get it
but just because you're not drinking
doesn't mean your addiction still exists
your dick is still there oh okay so the
addiction's there but right let's say
desire okay let's say I'm doing [__]
two-way balls a night right right and
tonight I quit doing [__] eight balls
okay right and I stay off it for [__]
22 [__] years and one day I start
snorting again guess what's gonna happen
late within a week I'm gonna be doing an
eighth I'm gonna be doing a quarter a
quarter is two eight balls because my
addiction's still growing I'll die of a
[__] heart attack God forbid I would
never do it I'm just telling you that
that's on addictions constantly growing
even if you're not doing the drugs
I I don't rest in peace or but isn't
that what happened in Philippines right
he went back and
uh came back from the [__] not doing
drugs you know I just respect my life
without the drugs
I really do
it's a [__] great experience I like
smoking the weed to calm me down a
little bit because sometimes I do get
hyper in the mornings
and they start sweating profusely and my
mind starts racing
so I think it helps me you know I think
in the real world if I went on to see a
psychiatrist I would have been on one of
those pills right now and I'd rather not
be on one of those pills that's why it's
my rather do three little bunk hits with
you in the morning in the morning Joy
and get the party started
but that's how you [__] survive a
probation
that's the only way especially when you
have a [__] family you have to start
thinking about them again not that I
thought about my family when I was out
there doing coping and I was 25 and 26
years old I was in the same boat as Jon
Jones
I was in the same boat as Jon Jones only
without the millions of dollars
there was no millions of dollars
involved but do you want me to tell you
something
even if there was at that time it
wouldn't have changed who I was
it would have just fueled My Fire
and I feel that because he didn't go to
that rehab that's always going to come
back to bite him in the ass
so do you think you should cancel the
fight and go to rehab I didn't say that
I didn't say that no that's not gonna
[__] happen
what I'm saying is that
sometimes when you don't take care of a
situation it comes back to bite you in
the ass later
take it from somebody who lived alive
for 27 [__] years
I lived a big lie for 20 [__] years
do I wish I would have went to a rehab
do I think a rehab would have helped me
between you and I not really
I think you're not ready to stop doing
drugs till you stop doing drugs I'm not
saying I'm not saying that
uh
he's doing drugs at all they would have
turned they could they would have ripped
him out of the car that night I'm not
saying he's doing drugs at all
but I'm saying that you know sometimes
you should take care of little things I
ended up going to a rehab but it was a
[__] rehab it wasn't no [__] real
rehab I wouldn't allow real rehab I
didn't want to get Unwound why was it a
[__] rehab
Christmas three to six every night four
days a week
how much how much how much can you
change somebody
from three to six four days a week for
[__] four weeks was it a world-class
instructor it was a different
instructors and all they did was agitate
the [__] out of me for nowhere you
understand me there what do they do they
just like drip Ranch on your forehand or
something
there was there was two women in
particular it was just one [__] older
woman
that had to be about 50.
and she was a sweet lady but you know
she was still a psychiatrist and she'd
ask your [__] creepy [__]
questions and ask you why and maybe this
and doesn't
and I thought I'd tell you something I
go in there and every time I left there
I left that [__] angry
it was [__] up for me I was snorting
while I was in there too
I was selling Coke from that rehab I
wasn't doing it I was still weighing it
in their bathroom and selling it you
didn't do whatever no I wasn't doing it
that time I was touching it with a piece
of paper and everything
so why do you keep going back
because I had to the court sent me that
no why do you keep going back if you
could stop doing coke
you made the decision to do it then oh
yeah I was doing it all the time at this
time the only reason why I stopped was
because I had an eye watching me
okay okay I was [__] him in the
halfway house
and even while I was in the halfway
house I was still [__] dealing
blowing snorting blow when they caught
me they wanted to put me back in jail
that's a probation violation that's a
violation of your court sentence
when you get sent to a halfway house you
have to piss in a [__] bottle so you
come back hot they have to make a
decision sometimes they take away your
freedom for 60 days and put you back in
the halfway house and they take away
your rights for 60 days so all you're
allowed to do is leave the house to
[__] work and sometimes they destroy
you in work release for [__] 90 days
or sometimes they wrap your [__] up and
throw you back in County
for [__] six months and then you have
to go back in front of a [__] judge
after that and he decides again what to
do with you
and then they give you a new probation
sentence because of the time you did
because wherever you did the time it
takes different days off
see prison time is like
two days for one day or three days for
every one day so if that's why when they
give you six years you do 42 months
because the sentence gets shortened but
when you do County jail time it's like
[__] gold it's like four days for one
day
so that's why when I give you a year in
County it's like four years it's like
seven months
do you follow me
oh so if you only get a year in County
yeah so you get a year and like every
institution is different so if you get a
year in County
you get like four days for everyone so
like if you get a year in prison you get
three days for everyone
so if you get a jail if you go to jail
and stay prison and you get a year you
do nine months
if you get that same year in state
prison you do seven months do you
understand me I understand you but
you're talking about seven months in
County Jail like it's like nothing like
what do you do with all your [__] when
you're about to go away for seven months
do you pay like seven months worth of
rent no you take your [__] you give it
to Paula and you say put this in your
house I'll see you in seven months you
come see me on Sundays don't put panties
on
that's a Utah
that's what you're telling or you pay
rent and she stays there
and takes care of animals and [__]
but usually when you put yourself in
that situation
you know I mean there's not much
but and then and let me even have to be
careful in prison because haven't there
been people who have been like maybe in
prison on a probation violation and
gotten sitting there and then I've spent
like years in there because of [__] they
did in there well listen man I don't
know anything about that I wish him a
lot of luck I really do I wish I love
him to death I wish Jon Jones oh yeah I
wish that uh he uh gets his handle he
goes in front of a judge tomorrow so
hopefully
by tomorrow afternoon we'll know it's
fake what the UFC decides
because this judgment [__] had months
to his probation
or make him do 90 days
and the judge doesn't give a [__] about
the UFC's event listen like I said they
gave a big chance I can't give you two
chances
and a Dane County Jail don't [__] cut
it in my world
and a lot of people at homegrown but
Joey the coppers
every cop in that town he did a hit and
run
he did a hit and run they all know his
vehicle the cop said he knew his vehicle
did he not I I didn't hear that part
maybe cop news vehicle they all know his
car now
but they see him at two in the morning
they're gonna pull him over just for
pulling them over
I seen you swear but no you didn't you
know whatever
and then that's why what I was thinking
is that's a bull's eye on you why did
they just leave oh Jon Jones go
somewhere else because he trains and
Winkle John and Santa Fe so
I'm sorry but if he's gonna be in prison
every other week for a fake probation
violation no no you can't run because
eventually the problem will catch up
with you there
he needs to live like I told you he
needs to live his life
he needs to train the daytime and at
night you're in with your family every
story even if he lives that way if he's
getting [__] it was every time he
leaves his house in the daytime and at
night it's completely differently
he's not gonna get [__] if you leave
your house you drive the speed limit you
stop at stop signs not even how you stop
you see how you stop at stop signs if
you're a celebrity and you got a
bullseye I will pull you over and give
you a ticket you do a Puerto Rican stop
you stop and keep rolling
no no no no no no no that's what people
do not realize why do you think whenever
I drive with you I make you stop exactly
the same way in every stop sign
because I never want you getting pulled
over
and they'll pull you over for that at 10
15 at night in a weird neighborhood
yeah I got pulled over why are you in
this neighborhood I didn't know I was
driving home if you've been drinking now
you got beef
right you understand me so anything that
happens at night and happens the daytime
is two different [__] worlds
okay in the daytime guess what I could
do in the daytime Lee what I could say
Lee what are you doing right now come
pick me up I have to go to [__] uh
okay to get a cheeseburger
let's go there at lunch time guess what
else I do what are you doing I call my
Coke deal
and they're gonna do me a favor
I'll give you 50 bucks extra meet me at
stop
don't let nobody see you when I get up
to go to the bathroom go to the bathroom
and I'll give you the cash that's how
quick it happens at lunch time I come
back I sit with you you didn't even
[__] see the move
you didn't even see the move why didn't
you just go pick it up because I'm
trying to tell you how do you avoid heat
I eat my [__] cheeseburger I get back
in the car with you and I go straight
[__] home and I ditch that [__]
cocaine you know why I have you there
why because you don't do Coke
I don't even want to hang out with
nobody who does coke
that's how [__] probation works okay
do I drink booze okay then now I'm gonna
call a friend of mine who drinks booze
but doesn't drink booze in the daytime
and I'm gonna say when you go to the
liquor store get me two bottles of
[__] booze not pay for your booze
I eliminated that Winkle John yeah you
go to the [__] gym and you drive home
you go train at [__] 7 A.M you stay
there till 12 you eat lunch over there
yeah bring lunch you hang out and you
[__] go home at 3 30.
and that's your day that's it that's the
way it has to be that's the only way
it's gonna work without attracting
attention
that's crazy anything at night you're
going to attract attention and guess
what guess what it's called when you
have the kiss of death on you you have
to kiss a death on you
he goes to a bar one night with the guys
from Winkle jump like we the Andrea
olowsky
Holly Holm they're going to celebrate
somebody's birthday
some guy has three drinks
calls Jon Jones the drunk or something
like that
there's a pushing argument that cops get
alerted guess who's going to jail John
Jones it happens 9 out of 10 times I
you have to avoid everything yeah just
don't be out you have to live your life
because it the numbers are high for
regular people
the percentages are high for guys like
you and I if we're involved in that
lifestyle
can you imagine for somebody who's got a
Target on his back
it just makes sense
when I got in trouble for the kidnapping
embolden and I lived in Boulder
afterwards
everybody knew how it had done it's not
breaking a window guy
it's not [__] uh
it was kidnappingly
kidnapping as a class one felony yeah
people know what you look like and they
know what you're dead yeah for some
people they're too stupid they don't
know but all you need to do is get
pulled over and they know everything
about you within [__] two minutes
and now you look that completely
different
when I come back to your car knowing
that you're a convicted felon now I have
my gang I have my hand on my gun
if you understand me that those words
so I knew one thing to do all my
business in the daytime so if you get
pulled over now will you say I'm a
convicted felon I'm not in two million
thousand years there's nothing on that
no more it's been over [__] 20 years
oh okay but right now you pulled me over
you're gonna get to go what were you
doing this neighborhood I went to do
comedy have you been drinking not at all
there's no [__] smell a pot in my
[__] car I don't smoke pot in my car
never no me either so what's what are
you pulling me over for
I do the speed limit only in on the
highways I do a little heavy foot
but besides that you're not gonna you
know what I'm saying
that's what it all comes down to that's
what tomorrow this [__] story is if
you're on [__] probation you have a
bull's eye on you you have to live a
[__] certain way
that's it plain and [__] simple
do you think the UFC should be letting
them fight like do you think I don't
know I don't know that's not that was
enough I don't even care about that okay
so what it's not about what this show's
about what we're talking about tonight
okay has nothing to do with the UFC man
this is what the [__] problem is with
Society I don't do it with the UFC it's
got to do with Jon Jones
and what he's going about about to look
at right now
you don't know what that if this judge
gives him a second chance
what if he gets in trouble again in six
months
so whatever's going on he's got to take
care of this I really want to find out
what time this video was shot at if
anybody knows let me see if I can find I
guarantee it's a time you shouldn't be
the [__] out of your house
especially if you're the world champion
or trying to [__] beat the world
champion in two months that's why it was
very weird if you look at that interview
between him and Joe Rogan
what does Daniel call me a say to him
just make sure you're there
and he goes you wish
that you you would be happy if that
wouldn't happen
because the percentages are always
[__] high man
yeah
it don't matter man no no it don't
[__] matter anyway this weekend I'm
at the [__] Brea Improv Thursday
Friday Saturday starting tomorrow night
is [__] Force One Star night if
you're in the neighborhood in April I
got two good [__] cities I'm going to
one of my favorites Buffy oh [__] oh
[__] how many wins he's gonna get just
six yeah
I got a couple of [__] beef on wicks
and also I'm going another one of my
favorite cities Indianapolis crackers
and that's it [__] it was a
great week I don't know what the [__] we
talked about tonight we got nice and
high
uh uh and that's it that's all I want to
[__] tell you guys you know me I keep
it simple though my [__] make up [__]
that don't exist
March was a great month we had a great
time together you know why [__] around
like I said man I get these people who
call me they send me stupid [__]
sometimes I look at them sometimes I
don't
like I said I sent to my attorney he
likes them sometimes we discuss it they
ran this by me and like I say I always
tell them you know what let me do it
once or twice see how they react to it
if they like it they'll let me know if
they don't like it we go to [__] hell
we don't do them no more I'm easy guys I
don't give a [__] about this this is
just to keep the lights on to keep
[__] Lee and [__] Chinese food
he's going to kettlebell class look at
him he's getting new clothes he's
thinking about moving a white friend
then he wants to make a pay have to rent
yeah
you should make more than I am [__]
she's gonna be [__] paying those
loans back and it's gonna send money to
Mexico
because it's got the chicken farm and
[__] and there you are sitting on the
car
you have the whole family living with
you you got people playing the drums in
your house you need this [__]
anyway people playing drums you know
what man let me tell you something I
am Cuban
but
I always like the [__] thing of being
American I don't know I really [__]
dug it I'm not playing I'm not I'm not
playing national anthem you know what
man I'll tell you what I still like
I tell you what I strive for
I wished I could look you in the face
Lee as my friend and my co-worker my
Goomba like I said guess what I did Lee
what did you do I went and bought two
tickets for us
to go to the Lakers and you're gonna go
really yeah let's go down there and on
the way down there you're gonna sit
there
and you're gonna go I wonder would Joey
paid for this
and you don't want to end up in the
[__] nosebleeds or in the middle so
they're 400 bucks
and at one point in the night
I mean yeah Laker game it's not the
Celtics
you know we live here we should support
the Lakers but at the end of the night
you're gonna go you know what Joey you
paid four for those and whether you
would have gave me a [__] steak
dinner for 250 and give me you know what
I'm saying give me cash you know what
I'm saying I'm sitting here like I'm
okay sitting here [__] eating and
whatever you said that to people no I
didn't say that to people but Lee this
is
expensive to go no way it's expensive to
go to games what then that's destroyed
my insides lately that I don't really
[__] talk about is you know what
they've done to America we can't go to a
[__] basketball game if you got two
kids and a daughter and a son and you
want to do a family now the [__]
baseball game there's some stadiums that
have dollar tickets but then your family
has to sit next to people of the [__]
animals and they drink and they burp and
they fart and I don't remember very many
who do have dollars today it's like 20
like family like it's a minimum of 20 or
40. you know and that you know people
it's just a [__] nightmare you gotta
pay 50 bucks to park anyway when I got
this I want to run it by you and just
see what you think what's the next big
event you want to go to you know what
what is it you know David Gilmore's
coming to your town maybe Black Sabbath
the final tour maybe you want to go see
a playoff game whatever it is you can
bet that someone's going to pay less for
better seats how they use a new company
called
scorebig.com they use a comp they use
scorebig.com you're paying too much for
tickets we all know that between the
markups and the last minute convenience
package even printed home fees you end
up paying Courtside prices for nosebleed
tickets this is why I don't go to these
events
scorebig.com is here to change that do
you know that 40 of all live tickets go
unsold and did you know that there's a
place these seats go at a huge saving
it's called scorebig.com
score big Works directly with your
favorite teams and artists to get their
unsold seats at unpublished prices only
at scorebig.com can you name a ticket
price and be guaranteed to pay below box
office up to 60 up to 60 percent off
here's what you do one go to
scorebig.com and find the event and
seats that you want two make an offer
for scorebig's name a ticket price
feature three get an instant answer and
save 60 on your ticket no surprise fees
and free shipping just um breathable
prices on great seats and more when
you're in great seats you actually enjoy
the game or the show or all the more I'm
telling you right now listen you've been
paying a bunch of money and you sit in
shitty seats it's all the Timeless and
it sucks ass and then you tell your
friends it was a good show but you don't
fit in the seed there's some [__]
animal next to you someone left the
lights on the last time and then exactly
what they're talking about we you will
be looking at something oh I have a
budget for what I want to spend and then
you and then as soon as you click on
it's like oh there's 47 in fees so
they're like no they're not gonna do
that so what we're gonna do is there's
no surprise fees and free shipping just
some beatable prices on great seats and
more when you're in great seats you're
actually enjoy it I'm telling you man it
tastes better anything tastes better
than a Muldoon anyway next time you go
see any game or show go to score big
first and see how much you can save go
to sport scorebig.com right now click on
the microphone enter the promo code Joey
j-o-e-y and you'll save an extra 20 off
your first ticket purchase again stop
paying too much for tickets man go to
scorebig.com right now promo code Joey
again
scorebig.com promo code Joey and also my
main men on it.com listen that protein
powder was delicious I got the shroom
Tech I took some today I did a lot
better in class my yeast still wet I'm a
firm believe right now I could sit here
and blow smoke up your ass listen I know
about this I know about that I know I
don't know dick I don't know dick all I
know is whenever I take out a product I
feel [__] great whether it's the
outfit I'm back on the Alpha Brain again
I'm a little sharper I mumble because
that's the wheat you know what I'm
saying what are you gonna do I've been
smoking since 6am what have you done
today anyway
Joe is here ready to [__] rock all
right like I told you I'm in Bray all
weekend but oh before we end let's go
back to honor here I want a little all
[__] thought here go to honda.com
right now I'm pressing church I get the
10 off of any product not weights or
anything just supplements and they
deliver it right to your door no drama
no money you're fun you like what you
read you get to stay on the program and
most importantly people still Alpha
Brain you give it a shot you don't like
it you send it back again 100 money back
guarantee what are these noise
you keep saying
and we could hear it stopping I'm sorry
I have no idea
anyway I want to thank my main man lee
Syed I want to thank you [__]
for listening we had a great March thank
you for making much uh just phenomenal
and wait wait to see what we have for
you in April I love you [__]
have a great weekend and a happy [__]
uh April Fool's Day [__]
this show is brought to you by scorpion
next time
before you go before you go go to score
big first and see how much you can save
go to scorebig.com right now click on
the microphone and enter promo code Joey
to get an extra 20 off your first ticket
purchase
and go to honor.com and use promo code
Church to get 10 off all of the great
optimization products
well anyone just close with this song
yeah
foreign
[Music]